the world of music in general is
changing very rapidly as it is in
business and in many areas in the 21st
century for someone to be able to invent
a successful career in music you have to
be able to use the environment out there
to your advantage by that I mean do you
embrace technology musicians now depend
less and less on someone else
a major recording company or or a PR
firm they are starting to self-produce
CDs they are on the internet they're on
YouTube they are doing many things that
are really brand new and in many ways
especially in classical music that said
it is to your advantage to have a career
that is multi-dimensional to just play
in a Symphony Orchestra or to just be a
member of an opera company or to just
play in a string quartet is a fine thing
to do certainly but instead of using the
job in a Symphony Orchestra as an end
they use it as a platform to do many
other things a very interesting example
of a multi-faceted career certainly
would be what we see with yo-yo ma and
what he is doing with the silk road
project you could certainly make the
argument that yo-yo doesn't need to do
these types of things but the fact that
as an artist he feels compelled to
explore music from Asia
using from a certain time and music that
was very localized and not necessarily
had exposure around the world he's
become a tremendous advocate for this
type of music and for this type of
career expansion a lot of musicians are
going in this in this direction that's a
fabulous way to have a very successful
and very rewarding career